[Music]
you collaborated for the film you
collaborated with formerly Snoop Dogg
now he's known as stoop lion lion yeah
I'm gonna go with Snoop Dogg he
collaborated with you on a song that you
wrote for the movie can you tell us
about that song yes the song is called
take yo panties off and as a song I
wrote you know I do comedy and I and I
played played keyboard and sing and one
day I was in Fort Worth Texas and there
was this waitress
and uh she just kind of was working
right in front of me and she had these
legs that wouldn't stop and take your
panties off it just came out my mouth
just I was like about eight years ago
that's how all the best songs are
written about you padded home so um
Snoop and I got together and we did kind
of a remix to it and it's on the
soundtrack you did a song called take
your pants off with Snoop Dogg with
Snoop Dogg and he is a very wise dude
he's he's uh he's a leader he came in
and he came and he brought a leader of
man it really he's got a lot of
knowledge and he gets in that studio he
don't mess around so uh I had to learn a
couple things
okay well movie this movies about even
he's like a leader in panty taking off
oh yeah that isn't even a handkerchief
is a hand towel hold out always hold out
a good it's a giant hand towel I always
keep a towel with me cuz I'm either
sweating or bouncing sweat that's the
really you'll see they get that sticking
here you see it in the movie too uh I
keep my talam itself it's monogrammed
[ __ ] mr. Robbins
this movies about the end of the world
okay I got to ask you are you one of
those people that thinks about like do
you think about what you would do do you
have like an earthquake preparedness kit
are you ready in case I thought goes
down I know I'm going to I would like to
be you know with my family if that you
know happens to come about and you know
eventually I need sex so hold my cousin
Charisse is there but the arm what well
I figured I would have a lot of water I
know cuz you can barter for things and I
would fashion some kind of size like on
my elbow right here eyesight yeah yeah
you know look like the cutting for the
kind of wheat like what depth carry we'd
have a giant blade on your hand I will
have no it will be right from here the
risk to the elbow so you could like
punch and kind of cut people you'd have
that and a towel ready for blah blah
blah and blah blah blah blah cube lot
that's a deadly combination